all right everybody you know the drill
we all know how we're voting but let's
get those sound bites for our donor
emails what are going to be the ground
rules today Bank politics I am upset
about the problem oh we haven't even
started we're going to be allowed to
interrupt yes knock knock who's there
interrupting protest or think approach
[Music]
doesn't pass the GIGO test okay okay
focus people focus we are here to talk
about a single person Hillary Clinton
Merrick garland Justice Kagan justice
Sotomayor every now sharpe Dilbert
lin-manuel Miranda George
Cavanaugh hi what a bastard Donald Trump
is we could drink in here right I think
the penalties are is being ousted from
the Senate I openly invite and accept
the consequences I feel like I'm a
problem I have prop for your thing have
you not seen one of these before
it's mostly a sham we know that every
Democratic member of this committee is
going to vote no you guys want to hear
about my judicial opinions I have over
300 put him in a box marked irrelevant
and set it aside if full of junk
these confirmation hearings haven't
worked for 31 years in America in
fairness Congress hasn't worked for 31
years either so
[Music]
I'm sorry that was harsh can we redact
that we slipped that into the thousands
of documents we don't talk about anybody
running for president over there how
much of this hearing is just
presidential campaign fodder 10 to 15
percent or 50 percent or 40 percent t9
Perce 100 percent well we got the room
for three more days should we watch a
movie we've never had a request for a
video for an Alice in Wonderland we've
seen this movie before
here Dinesh D'Souza has a new comedy we
need Schoolhouse Rock back look I
appreciate Schoolhouse Rock but we're
not children
we're senators we all understand the
concept of object permanence don't do
that what's being hidden what is being
hidden all right it is clearly not
reflective of current reality that was
before judges were viewed as
policymakers there's no verse of
schoolhouse rock that says give a whole
bunch of power to the alphabet soup
agencies and let them decide what the
governance decision should be for the
people because the people don't have any
way to fire the bureaucrats because
people can't navigate their way through
the bureaucracy they turn to the Supreme
Court looking for politics god help me
you are making sense are you sure you're
in the right room the Supreme Court
becomes our substitute political
battleground it's gotten really bad you
know there's been a hundred and thirteen
justices confirmed to the Supreme Court
right at first sixty six were confirmed
without even holding a hearing not one
senator voted against Justice Scalia's
confirmation wit Scalia our democracy is
on trial guilty and how much more beer
should we get thousands of additional
cases good call
mr. the question we are being asked to
address in this hearing among others is
whether this judge at this time in our
history will administer the law with
equal justice and dignity of equal
treatment regardless of if they live in
a poor neighborhood or a rich
neighborhood or if they live in a small
house or the White House what about a
little pink house eminent domain
google it most of my life has been spent
in the court he was acquitted he is a
judge with a clear record yep that seems
pretty clear to me you've been accused
of hating women not true hating children
kind of hating clean-air know wanting
dirty water I call a bourbon everyone
knows that you served in the Bush
administration damn it
I've known you and your reputation for
nearly 30 years I don't know who you are
as you know well we went to the same law
school we clerked in the same courthouse
in Wilmington Delaware so oh oh you got
super bald you know we've had a lot of
fun today but the current state of
politics in Washington is no laughing
matter
and neither is jurisprudence or judicial
confirmations the third and equal branch
of government under our Constitution is
one of the most important
[Music]